[Music]
and if here's Kristin Cavallari is
returning to reality TV a source tells
ET that the former Hales and Laguna
Beach star landed a new reality series
set to premiere on e sometime later this
year the show will focus on her life as
a mom of three and the wife of NFL Pro
Jay Cutler but don't expect to see her
kiddos five-year-old Camden
three-year-old Jackson and two-year-old
sailor will not be featured here's what
Kristen's told ET in the past about
putting her kids on TV I want my kids to
grow up as normal as possible and I just
don't think that you can grow up normal
with a camera in your face yeah I don't
even put my kids on social media I'm
under 18 you know they want to pursue a
career in entertainment then it's a
different story and we can talk about it
I would almost rather my kids play
football and do reality TV Cavalier ease
news show comes a week after she
revealed on Spencer Pratt and Heidi
Montag podcasts make Spidey famous again
said she wouldn't rule out a Hills
reunion show the sentiment she expressed
to ET last April like doing the hills
again I would be open to it if it could
be more about our businesses or just the
girls catching up rather than our family
lives but I think it'd be fun to do a
reunion